Je dirais un autre parce que c'est à
bref délai j'ai des sénateurs avec
ce régime vous verrez Fernanda McDonald invoquer
le Règlement afin que les sénateurs
ne soient pas intimidés pourriez-vous demander à ces
sénateurs tous les sénateurs d'aborder la
question par votre intermédiaire en tant que  président plutôt
que de s'adresser à des sénateurs individuels
Merci sénateur McDonald Je ne pense pas qu'il y
ait un point d'eau là-bas et sénateurs,
je rappellerai simplement aux sénateurs que les bandes dessinées
doivent être adressées par l'intermédiaire du président
Merci m.  président, le commentaire
du président est que vous savez que McDonald a
vraiment une obsession malsaine
pour moi, mais je m'égare en revenant en
revenant à la question
en cours
en revenant à la question en cours
vous n'êtes pas mon genre non plus les femmes de chambre  ne vous
inquiétez pas pour
revenir à la question à l'étude,
McDonald intervient continuellement à
propos de la mauvaise réunion du sénateur, sa
contribution est très désordonnée, vous
savez que des échanges solides sont tous essentiels dans
cet endroit, mais il y a un contenu de
Sarah a McDonald pour les sénatrices et
côté gauche de la chambre
[Musique]